Priyanka how's my little sister doing
good she's good
I mean how am I doing this from Citadel
to love again to the Met Gala with that
gorgeous necklace I mean we're seeing
all the behind the scenes with uh Nick
posting and Gaga going all over you
um how are you
it's a little bit tired
um you know it's been a massive promo
run for me it's been two really
important projects for me
um one on your TV and one in your
theaters so it's um it's really cool
these are two characters that I love
playing and I have invested a part of
myself and both of them so it feels
really gratifying and you know the
adrenaline from loving the work that
you've done kind of keeps you going but
um today Sam may have seen a side of me
which was wilting slowly really well and
it's incredible and yeah it's amazing
you're still going yeah kudos to you so
how did Nick get involved did he suggest
he'd be the Bumble date and two what was
it like he's gonna be like yo could I do
a cameo in your movie no girl
we had to um yeah not convince him but
we were shooting this in covid and they
were supposed to cast
a random actor to do this makeout scene
with me and you know he's licking my
face and it was just all I don't it was
all weird and Nick was in town
um to help me settle in I was supposed
to move to London for a year and a half
for Citadel after love again and Jim our
director was like should we just ask him
and I said yes we must
um and Nick was so gracious and lovely
and he agreed to do it thank God but he
took one for the team he really did he
really did it's really funny and Sam one
of the sexiest moment in this film is
you singing to Celine Dion you know all
by myself and then
you will be singing it all by yourself
uh yeah I wouldn't say it's sexy I think
uh it might turn a lot of people off but
um certainly no we had a lot of fun on
the movie and uh it's uh he's such a
great character to play I really enjoyed
sort of um playing Rob he's kind of
neurotic and and his he you know when he
first meets Celine he's he's like very
cynical about it he thinks her music
sucks and uh by the end of the movie
he's a full convert
uh and I understand that you actually
didn't shoot with her in person but did
you have a chance to connect with her
after she talked about her health in
December
yeah I mean there were a lot of issues
and mostly it was due to covid really we
couldn't obviously fly people in and out
we were in a bubble in the UK it was the
height of one of several lockdowns so
it's kind of crazy that even this movie
came together that we got to make it
um we overcame many obstacles and I know
Celine has her own um you know obstacles
to overcome with her health but we just
wish her all the best and she's such an
integral part of the movie her music is
so uplifting it really is a celebration
of her so we're we sort of we say we
just love we love you Celine
and the fact oh they're wrapping me
already I was gonna do a quick question
for you would you rather
be serenaded by Celine Dion or cardi B
Celine Celine Dion I love cardi she's my
girl
I just want to say that as well Priyanka
I'm so happy for you and we love you so
much so thank you for everything you're
doing get some sleep nice to meet you
Sam happy belated in a few days bye
[Music]